[Music]
good morning everyone we ready to get
started welcome to today's presentation
where we're going to talk about how to
build reliable applications on gcp with
our customers Crews and
ignite so here's what we're going to
cover today we will start with something
called as deployment archetypes uh I'll
go into a little bit more detail on what
that means uh think of it as grounding
ourselves in a little bit of theory
before we get to the real world examples
starting with Cruz followed by ignite
and then at the end of the session we'll
take Q&A we have timed all of our talks
we will have plenty of time for Q&A so
we will take that at the end so if you
have questions please take a note of
them I promise you we will get to them
okay now before we dive in you're
probably wondering who we are so it
makes sense to introduce ourselves and
we will start with you NES hi my name is
nitish I'm on the container platform
team in the infrastructure Aug at Cruz
um I've been with Cruz about four years
and um yeah great to meet you
all Roman hello I'm Roman Kleiner I'm a
VB of engineer in at ignite and I'm
responsible for everything to do with
ignite's platform including how it
transer
gcp Le hey everybody my name is Lee
Gates I work at Google Google Cloud
studying reliability availability and
performance and happy to be here with
you today and excited for our talk
wonderful folks my name is Tim Isaacs I
lead gcp platform reliability from a
product management standpoint and I'm
super excited to be here and uh lead you
through the next 10 or 15 minutes before
we move to the other speakers wonderful
let's get started so um what are we
going to cover today uh the key
objective here is to discuss a few
deployment architectures what we call
deployment archetypes it's just another
way of seeing deployment
architectures and then um run through
those with two case studies one from
Cruz and nsh will walk us through that
and the other from egnite so what we're
trying to do here is start with a little
bit of theory and then match that theory
with some real world examples a quick
sidebar what you see linked below is a a
link to the to a very popular paper it's
called Cloud uh archetypes deployment
archetypes for cloud applications sorry
it's um uh I would encourage you folks
to to read it uh you can find it online
it's a fairly straightforward search the
authors are googlers but there's nothing
Google specific about the paper so it's
a very generic cloud-based paper and uh
really good information and there I've
read it a couple of times so I
definitely encourage uh doing so uh
yourselves okay so what are these
archetypes that we are harping on uh
very simply put um we you should think
of these archetypes as deploying an
application in a Zone you'd call that a
zonal archetype or in a region a
regional archetype across two or three
regions that's a multi- region archetype
and then if you're going across all
regions across the world you would call
that a global application or a global
archetype each has certain variants that
are more descriptive in name and we're
not going to have time to cover all of
these we will pick a few and given that
this talk is centered on reliability we
will examine them more from an
availability and reliability
lens right and what you'll see is these
are effectively design patterns that
optimize for a few things they optimize
along Dimensions like available
uh cost and complexity latency and at
the end of the day it's just a balance
of trade between these dimensions and
really what you're trying to do here is
you're trying to match your business
requirements of your applications to one
of these one of these
archetypes okay um you know generally
speaking if it's a zonal
archetype you're deploying into a single
zone uh you may have a failover zone so
you can't expect very high availab
on the other hand if you're deploying
across multiple regions you have your
application now in multiple regions
across multiple zones so you can
tolerate various kinds of failures and
therefore you can expect a much higher
availability right so that's the
intuition behind uh these different
design
patterns so let's dive in the first one
is what we call a single zone with
failover Zone it's the most
straightforward one to also understand
and if I get your attention to to the
picture on the right there uh you
basically have your application deployed
in one zone the primary Zone it's also
very simple application just you know of
front end if you will in this example
with a database you're keeping a read
replica of your database that's not
active in another Zone and when you have
a failure you fail over to the second
Zone if you've de deployed applications
in the on premises world this will look
somewhat familiar where you have an
applic in data center one you have
another data center not that far away
and then you use that data center for
fail over when something goes wrong
either to your application or to the
physical data center itself so what that
also means is when you are uh trying to
do a on-prem to Cloud migration if you
follow this design pattern it's more of
a lift and shift you're not doing a
whole lot of re
architecture uh therefore cost and
complexity also is on the low side but
but because you're only deployed in a
Zone you can't again expect a whole lot
of of you can't have high availability
expectations 3 9 is roughly where you
will tap
out
okay so with that simple example to
start let's move to the next one now
this is single region now just the
picture alone will tell you that's a
little bit more
complicated and what you're doing here
is you're deploying your application
across three different zones within that
region you can therefore tolerate a Zone
failure or even a multizone failure
right you can tolerate two zones failing
because your application is deployed
across all three in this example you're
using a little bit of a modern
architecture you have a front end load
balancer for your front ends you have a
backend load balance end then your back
ends and a backend data store you have
three copies of your data one's active
the other two are replicas on
standby and um if a Zone fails you
You're simply redirecting traffic
through your load balancers to the other
zones um and if your zones back up and
running or your application in the zone
is back up and running then you're using
all three zones to serve your
application now if you're doing a
migration from the on Prem world then
there is some level of re architecture
that you'd have to do because this is a
little bit more of a scaleout uh
architecture and that also means from a
best practices standpoint you have to
start thinking about things like
autoscaling your applications as load
increases or scaling down or load
shedding as load decreases or if you
have some sort of a problem with a
portion of your
application the nice thing though is um
if you're using uh Google Cloud managed
products you tend to have constructs
like these that help you out so there's
something called as migs managed
instance groups people who have worked
on Google Cloud are probably familiar
with this it takes care of a lot of
things like autoscaling out or scaling
in um when it comes to block storage we
have something called as Regional
persistent disc which uh effectively uh
creates two copies of your storage uh
synchronously so they're kept up to date
between two zones within the region so
again if a Zone fails you have a copy in
another Zone that would be up and
running so um the single region you can
typically expect about 49 of of uh
availability okay so at this point let's
actually walk through a little bit of an
example and what we're trying to do here
is we're trying to derive a SLO right so
at the end of the day you're going to be
using a set of Google products and
resources uh in Google cloud and then
you have to think about hey at the
application Level how do I derive or
think about a SLO service level
objective and in this example we try to
keep it somewhat simple we have three
components you have the load balancer
that's uh bringing in requests then you
have your compute side in this example
we're using gke and then of course you
have your database uh in this case it's
SQL if you look at the product level
slas that you get from each of these the
load balancer the SLA is 49 so under the
covers clearly we are doing a bunch of
things to make sure it's 49 you're
abstracted from it so all you see is you
know a regional load balancer that has a
um you know fairly High
SLA and then uh the gke Clusters here
are zonal clusters so you have an SLA of
about two and a half two and a half
nines and then of course on the SQL side
if you're using manage SQL or Cloud SQL
uh you get three and a half 9es now
that's not good enough if you're trying
to construct an application let's just
say with four nines so what you do is
you start adding redundancy right so you
deploy GK you deploy your application
across multiple zones as we saw in the
archetype so you're now deploying gke
across multiple zones you're doing the
same thing with SQL here we just used
two copies of SQL it could very well be
three and as you're adding D dunany of
course you're raising the availability
right intuitively that makes sense and
the way you'd do that Math course it's a
bit theoretical but the way you do that
math is 1 minus the error budget raised
to the number of um redundant copies
that you have so in this example with GK
it's 1 minus the error budget is
005 raised to the power of three because
you have three
copies you do the same thing for SQL and
then you get some numbers now the fact
of the matter is those numbers are a bit
theoretical the reality is you will
finally be bounded by something else
within the region could be some
dependency or the fact that physical
infrastructure can only give you so much
availability within a single region and
that bound usually tends to be about 49
so now what do you end up with you have
three components each giving you about
49 if you architect your overall
application in such a way that they
aren't fully dependent on each other
when it comes to failure modes then you
can expect that your application itself
can also achieve about
49s so that's a way to just think about
your application Level SLA when you're
using Google products and Google
products typically
publish an SLA and um You probably have
to add an redundancy in some cases to
get to your target SLA okay so that was
an example with single region now let's
go and get a little bit more advanced
and now let's talk about a single region
with a failover
region now as you can see in that
picture what are we doing here we have
taken the single region archetype and
we' have said hey you know what we need
to also have something similar in
another region a pho region so your
application is again deployed across
three zones in the region um same setup
as before but you have your data being
replicated into a standby region so
you're probably doing async replication
if your region is far away and then um
when there's a failure you're going to
fail over into your standby region and
you're going to spin up your compute
resources either just in time or you
might pre-provision
uh it all depends on what you're trying
to optimize
for this is certainly a more complex
archetype uh customers typically Reserve
this for the mission critical
applications rather than all of your
applications uh as you can see the cost
of this is going to be a bit on the
higher side uh complexity is also going
to be a bit on the higher side and one
thing that you really should take care
of from a best practices standpoint is
making sure that you are well aware of
the health of your application through
the stack the reason for that is you
don't want to fail over unnecessarily
because failing over to another region
is going to be a high cost activity
right you are spinning up new resources
you're trying to make sure that your
application comes up in the right order
you are moving your clients there you're
also operating on a copy of data that's
probably 10 15 minutes behind right so
your rpos in the order of 10 15
minutes so you want to make sure that
you're really failing over when I
whether your region goes down or your
application within the region goes
down right another thing that you should
think about is if your application is
really large taking up a lot of
resources is that you have capacity in
the region that you're filling over into
so some capacity planning in advance is
a good idea one of the things that uh
customers do is they pre-provisioned
resources ahead of time or they do
frequent Dr tests to make sure that when
um something bad happens you have tested
enough to know that you will fail over
um and things will all work okay so
that's single region with a fellow
region sometimes you we call this a dual
region architecture right because you do
have two
regions the last one is more of a true
dual region architecture where each
region has an isolated stack so again
you're taking your application you're
deploying it in three zones within a
region but you're doing exactly that in
another region and these are both active
copies of your application so you're
serving clients from both regions you
have a load balancer uh some sort of a
you know DNS load balancer that's
appropriately uh partitioning your
traffic into the two different regions
and so what happens is if a region fails
you still have your other region that's
serving traffic and uh you can decide
how you want to handle that situation
you can either redirect all your users
from the failed region to this surviving
region or you can say hey you know what
I'll operate in degraded mode and I'll
only serve about 50% of my users um
appropriately or I'll serve all of my
users slowly right so it's up to you how
you want to sort of handle that again
depends on your business
goals clearly this is a more expensive
and more complex design right you have
many copies of
your application that's actively running
so you're actively you know spending
during that time and it's certainly more
complex because you have many moving
parts and you have to make sure they're
all well
coordinated so again this is a much like
the previous one this is something that
you would reserve for your mission
critical applications versus just every
application that you
have Okay so let's do a quick recap um
so we discussed the concept of
deployment archetypes simply put is just
deployment architectures or deployment
patterns um we discussed four of them um
you can Loosely classify them into a
single region versus a dual region
design and uh you go higher up in
availability but you're trading off cost
and complexity when you do so as you go
from a single region to a dual region
and therefore you must make sure that
you're appropriately matching the
archetype to your business goals
okay so this is the end of the the
theory bit to build a little bit of a
foundation that we can now use with our
rur world examples and to talk through
that we will start with Cruz and I'm
going to hand over to
NES can you hear me okay
awesome okay so um we from Cruz uh
hopefully all of you have heard about us
we a driverless car company based here
in SF uh but before I talk about our
business application uh of these
deployment archetypes I'm going to just
look at a summary here right so this is
based off what Tim just talked about
what deployment AR type are we choosing
and why so immediately you'll see we
have like a pretty high requirement of
five NS of reliability I'll talk about
why a little bit later uh we're using
multiple regions so it's a dual region
but it could also be three regions if
you wanted to instead of two and we use
uh Regional GK clusters as our basis in
each of those regions so even within a
region we're using Regional Services
instead of zonal
services um for and then for our
applications we sort of have like three
layers that our applications use this is
pretty standard we have like a database
layer for which we use multi-region
cloud spanner the great thing about
Cloud spanner is like multi-region out
of the box we have a messaging layer I
have a St about that talk about later
and then we have a custom load balance
that we' have built to uh distribute
traffic across our different
regions okay so about Cruise um even if
you've not heard about it still now like
we've been in news a lot recently um all
of you are in SF which I think is far to
say is the driess capital of the world
driess car capital of the world um we
are a self-driving car company um
headquartered here we're building the
world's most advanced self-driving cars
and these safely connect people to the
places things and experiences they care
about um quick show of hands how many of
you have actually been in a self-driving
car not that many how many of you want
to be in a self-driving car sometime
soon many of you right so that that Gap
is exactly what we're hard at work in uh
at cruises right now to fulfill um we
are rapidly expanding we recently
announced that we have gone to our 12th
and 13th markets it's very fast I think
we're testing now in Seattle and
Washington but we've been deploying
we're going to be deploying services to
Charlotte and Raleigh in North Carolina
as well so you can see where we are as
as a company right we have a product
that works it works in a few markets
like right now we have public services
in SF Austin and Phoenix Phoenix but
very soon it's going to be across the US
geographically and it's going to be
having multiple Vehicles right hundreds
thousands of vehicles and many many
customers so how do we take something
that's built reliably in one place and
sort of expand that across the country
and expand that to a huge set of
customers here um we have a unique
product obviously uh the AVS themselves
have prettyy high availability
requirements um think of them as sort of
like iot devices right so they're iot
devices but they're also like constantly
on the move across these cities they're
also constantly on the Move
geographically spread right so you have
AVS in Miami as well as Austin as well
as LA and these are constantly talking
to our Cloud backends right like where
do I go next to pick up a passenger um
should I go back to get charged into the
garages and our ride hill and delivery
products that we're building on top of
this technology will only be reliable if
the AVS themselves are extremely
reliable in terms of how they
communicate with the cloud
backends okay next so uh a couple years
ago we were in R&D mode right and when
we were in R&D mode we used a single G
speed region so I'm showing you the
before right so that you can see our
journey here so when we were in R&D mode
we had a single region a single Regional
gke cluster and we had sort of these
monolithic Services deployed in each of
those zones and all of them used
cloudsql DBS which is a regional product
and GB Pub sub which is also a regional
product we had load balancers that were
pretty straightforward just sending
traffic across those zones within a
single cluster and the AV is stocked
only to a single region at this point
and um yeah this is sort of similar to
what Tim showed you before in a single
region architecture we did not have like
a failover or anything like that right
at this point we were only focused on
getting the technology itself to work so
like reliability was like know the next
step okay so what comes next so what
comes next is um SL okay what comes next
is 59s right I toally talk about 59s so
59 is like 26 seconds per month of
downtime it's very very low but think
about the experience of a customer in a
driess vehicle being stuck for 26 26
seconds on the road in the middle of the
night right it's very uncomfortable
experience compared to like not being
able to access a website or an
application for a minute or two right so
we want to make sure that the experience
our customers get is extremely reliable
and we know that we can only give that
reliability with this level of Cloud
reliability itself we are also in a nent
industry and this is very important it's
a highly regulated nent industry right
so we have to also prove to the to the
government our Regulators that this is a
product that they can trust that our
customers can trust and that is going to
help us spread this product across the
US so the F uh the fin NES here are not
something we get easily right it's
something we have to archit toward words
um some of the examples that Tim showed
you before like show a path to go from
like 3 9 to 49 to 59 and that's sort of
like our journey here to towards those
Finance of
reliability uh the other thing I want
you to note here is the applications
here are consistently deployed across
the different regions it means that we
have sort of minimized the amount of
refactoring we have to do I talked about
the monolithic applications we had a
little before um by deploying
consistently across many regions it's
easy for our service developers to be
like hey I have this one version of my
micros service I just want all the AVS
everywhere to use it right and the
architecture that we've built sort of
allows them to do that um it makes it
easier for them to deploy their code to
these Cloud
backends okay I want to focus in on the
layers that we have as part of
architecture and we'll dive into a
couple of these layers A little later if
you look at each of these layers each of
them have to have uh Finance reliability
so the cool thing is with the SP
database layer that's multi-regional GSP
service that gives us Finance out of the
box so that's not a problem we had to
solve the next layer down is pubsub so
that's gcp pubsub which is a regional
service so we had to architect Finance
of reliability with that and then we
have the GK clusters which again are
Regional and then we have the load
balances which are Regional so you'll
see that at the bottom those are our AVS
right and our AVS talk to a custom uh
DNS load balancer which directs it uh to
different regions to use and and that is
also like Finance of reliability right
so layer by layer if all those layers
have Finance of reliability we get
Finance of reliability overall I think
he showed you the math slide as well Tim
for
that okay so uh the two big things that
we built here that we had to build in
house are the custom DNS uh load
balancer and the uh gcp pops sub
architecture I'll talk about the traffic
layer first you'll see here that we have
two Regional clusters these are like
active active you could call them and
the a has to be able to talk to them uh
without like a failure like a Time taken
for fail over right so what happens here
is we have a custom DNS load balancer
that is constantly Health checking our
most critical Services you can see that
let's say service a and service B are
two critical Services deployed to
different clusters they have their
custom health checks with which the
custom DNS load balancer can check for
and it'll only direct the AV to talk to
a backend if it knows that's a healthy
backend service in that region the same
thing is also applied for East West
traffic so if you imagine that service a
goes down in region Us West one service
B can actually talk to service a in
uswest 2 using the same load balancing
logic and when a health check fails it's
removed obviously from the DNS uh
response so no no AV after that is going
to be using that um a little more about
this custom DNS load balancer some of
our applications are very latency
sensitive right obviously we need to
have like command and control of these
vehicles they need to respond very
quickly to them so the DNS layer itself
is configured with locality based load
balancing sort of means that the AVS
themselves know which Market they're
operating in and when they ask for a
response who which Cloud end point I'm
are supposed to talk to they get the one
closest to them assuming that's always
healthy right it's only when the one
closest to them is not healthy that it
gets redirected somewhere else so it's
not like a random load balancing or like
a no fully distributed load balancing
it's definitely locality based for those
latency sensitive
applications uh so this this is I think
the most useful slide to you honestly
speaking this is how we deployed a
regional Pub sub um uh service and made
it like multi-regional and got like
Finance reliability out of it um so we
have an at least one messaging
requirement out of our messaging uh
service but because gcp pop sub is only
can only be deployed in a single region
we have to get Finance of reliability by
deploying them in each region and having
all your subscribers subscribe to all of
them and all your Publishers writing to
all of them them so this is obviously
more expensive but it also means that if
an entire region goes down right all our
subscribers and all our Publishers can
still read from different regions
immediately without like a lot loss of
um
messages um yeah so this is how we got
from like a thing that does not have
like out of the box Finance of
reliability to something that something
that will give us Finance of
reliability okay I think I'm need to
hand off to Roman now thank you so
much
hello am I audible yeah awesome all
right so I'm going to talk to a little
bit about ignite um it's a slightly
different product and architecture and I
what I'll try and discover more of those
archetypes that Tim talked about in his
opening
overview now
um um with a Gite we actually used
several archetypes
I'll begin with one which kind of talks
more about our car product and in that
case we have an active region with a
fail over region kind of scenario and in
a moment I'll explain a little bit why
that is and what power is that overall
we are using more or less standard gcp
Technologies so we don't have too many
custom components within that uh but
before I go much deeper um Let me let me
talk a little bit what ignite does
because unfortunately I cannot make the
same assumption that the previous
speaker did so ignite uh has pretty much
two main pillars of functionality that
we sell to our many customers and we
have 20,000 plus of these one is what
you would call FAL system in the cloud
or Advanced collaboration so you have
your company they need to work on same
content they work need to work on mutal
projects they want to do it in seamless
way wherever they are right um and it
from the more basic use cases that you
can readily imagine to pretty Advanced
ones that are tailored for a particular
industry such as construction and then
we have another pillar where people are
administrators in our case they would
want to reason about their data and
understand that it's been processed in
the right way that there are no
accidental or intentional incidents so
this is like a full analysis whereas an
administrator can come in and say oh
this is something I need to worry about
when it comes to data in my environment
so um when we look at all of that the
main aspects that really would matter
and I'll come to them in a moment is
durability because if there is one thing
one thing that we cannot really afford
is for anyone to lose their data they
entrust us with their
data it has always to be the right one
it has to be the current one it cannot
be lost
um again to put things in contrast
availability matters a lot because if as
a customer you cannot access your data
in most cases you cannot function as a
business but that being said if we are
ever facing the very difficult choice of
keep your data correct or keep it
unavailable for a little bit durability
would Trump because durability will stay
forever availability might come back in
a few minutes right and I'm sure some of
you have similar applications where you
have those kind of long-term versus
short-term concerns again I'm not saying
availability doesn't matter and in a
moment I'll go at length about how we
are trying to reach if unit St too but
we always have as Architects think what
matters the most right and what are the
difficult choices that we have to
construct when we look at a system now
um one aspect I didn't put on the slide
but I'm sure everyone has it in their
back of their mind is cost because what
we want to do is of course provide the
right availability but also manage arti
so we can provide competitive pricing
remain profitable all the things that
all of us want to be at and that kind of
plays from a third angle into the
architecture so I kind of want to keep
all of this in the back of our minds
durability availability cost when we
review all of that and of course
security matters without saying I'm not
going to talk a little a ton about that
aspect but I do want to highlight that
we're a little bit like GP in the fact
that yeah we hold the data for our
customers but we can't access it that's
not our data that's their data right so
that also needs to be at the kind of at
the kernel of the thinking that the
engineering has when it comes to
multi-tenant systems like that um now
what I want to do next is kind of take a
vertical slice through the most basic
use case I don't want to throw my entire
architecture or entire architecture at
you but kind of exemplify that thinking
through a through one example and this
is the most straightforward one somebody
go comes in and wants to retrieve a file
you know retrieve some content um and uh
in that
case we first would go through a global
load balancer and that Global Lo
balancer would first of all tell where
you are because we have customers around
the globe and we are running multi
regions but you are from birth as a
customer from that point you became a
customer you are being assigned
somewhere it could be Us West Us East
Europe but you're
somewhere um and at the point your
request comes in we are already multi we
decide okay your request lands at say
Zone B in in US West okay let's let's
work with that assumption for a moment
uh and then we go through our API
gateways we go through our cash we go
through all of the optimizations that um
I put there and for Simplicity I even
omitted like half of them but the main
point is let's say the request Comm in
and boom availability is Zone goes off
in the middle of that or a particular
service in that availability Zone it can
happen right and you can uh you can say
that's like a three nights kind of event
so the way we constructed that is by
default we stay within availability Zone
but if something happens we jump to the
to the adjacent one and one can ask why
don't you do that by default why don't
you just uh because they are close by
latency shouldn't be a big deal but for
us costs now I go back to that principle
I mentioned because we deal with
petabytes of data we deal with terabytes
of data that probably got downloaded
since I got on this stage you know in
ignite's case so we really have to
manage our costs and we don't want to do
cross availability Zone traffic just
because we can right we want to do it
only if we have to and that's part of
this how the system was architected and
of course if availability Zone goes
entirely uh for a while at that point we
go and we uh um uh all of the requests
will land on a given availability Zone
going forward right so now let's ask the
question what happens if an entire
region goes down right that's probably
the question that front of mind but um
in that case we have going back to the
archetypes active in a fail over if you
remember team's overview that was the
third archetype that he covered so we
have this fail over region where we
constantly go and we PR provision uh our
Computing there we constantly replicate
the data there it's always current but
it's not serving
requests and I'll tell in a moment why
because that sounds you have it why
don't you go the whole way right so I'll
explain in a moment why it's we want
don't want to do that but first let's
see if a region goes down we go and we
take a decision and we move to read that
readon region right there and then now
uh why don't we want to have them live
all the time now I go back to that first
principle I talked about durability and
data recency because now many of you
probably know what cap theorem is and
how difficult it is to achieve it skill
now we want the data to be consistent so
let's say I'm here editing some file and
somebody is there in the other part of
the globe is Ed in the same file and
they have different regions serving that
one going out so you can imagine how
many cases now we have to deal with not
to lose any of our two modifications to
that content it's almost impossible if
not completely impossible I don't
remember the theory but let's say it's
if somebody manages to do that they can
command a ton of respect and money so
what we do basically we are saying okay
we want to simplify that active fail
over and if we fail over we do first
What's called the read only failover so
you can access your data but you cannot
modify it yet because we still if that
region is not fully out and it's still
doing some kind of semblance of life in
it we still might be in a tough spot but
if that outage is prolonged we cannot
tell our customers say you know we can
only read your data you can modify it
for some time so that point okay let's
upgrade the fill over to a primary at
that point it's a oneway street at that
point basically that becomes the primary
and and that one might become now the
failover and of course it would inol
some more so that's kind of a pattern
that I don't think is that unique to
ignite if you kind of think about it in
new architect your systems you worry
about cost you worry about um
availability it's definitely worth
considering in many scenarios
um so at this
point um I'll just quickly want to give
one little counter example and then
we'll pass to my colleagues for Q&A so
back in the beginning I mentioned we've
got two products or not products but
let's say pillars and I mentioned there
was one admin pH in where as an
administrator you can look at the stance
of your data um and there we actually
have a slightly different archetype
because here the stakes are a little bit
different of course as an admin you
cannot flight blind right if suddenly a
region went down it cannot just we
cannot tell you okay for 2 days we will
not this thing will not be active but
that's different from saying nobody can
collaborate in your company right that's
a slightly different level of impact so
here we are running single region we
don't have a failover region but we can
easily create one on demand and the data
is replicated so unlike with that
previous example where we can like Snap
our fingers and get a fail over within
an hour half an hour whatever here might
take maybe half a day and again that
goes back to the principle where
constantly trying to balance and see and
do exactly the right amount of
availability not more not less something
that gets us to the right cost
[Applause]
bracket